aujourd'hui c'est mon anniversaire oui
oui et dans les commentaires je vous
laisse essayer de deviner ménages juste
pour voir un petit peu le l'âge que vous
me donnez en fait puis comme je suis
déjà très gâtée mais en fait j'ai décidé
que ce serait moi qui vous ferait un
cadeau en fait en fin de vidéo donc
rester bien jusqu'à la fin parce que va
y avoir un petit truc pour vous non mais
en vrai dans cette vidéo on va aussi
parler d'une caméra de ouf
mais ça ce sera juste comme d'hab après
l'intro et salut à tous les amis c'est
françois pour la chaîne explique mme
encore je suis ravie comme toujours je
suis hyper heureux de vous retrouver une
nouvelle fois pour une nouvelle vidéo
et puis si vous n'êtes pas encore abonné
à la chaîne sachez qu'ici on parle de
caméras on parle de montage on parle de
tournage bref tout ce qu'il faut pour
faire de la vidéo donc si ce n'est pas
déjà le cas vous pouvez bien entendu
cliquer sur le petit bouton s'abonner la
cloche tout ça tout ça parce que sur
cette chaîne y aura forcément des choses
qui vont vous intéresse vous l'avez vu
dans le titre aujourd'hui on va parler
d'une icône z6 et c'est une caméra qui
m'a clairement ni sur le cul parce
qu'elle a quelques petites choses en
plus qui vraiment font la différence
juste avant je vous expliquais d'ouges
la source est caméra parce que ça me
paraît quand même assez important
il ya quelques mois j'ai été contacté
par nikon pour tester pour avoir un prêt
de 7,6 pour pouvoir un petit peu voir ce
que ça donnait et honnêtement j'étais
pas hyper emballé j'étais très satisfait
de ce que j'avais mais je me suis dit
pourquoi pas finalement on me propose de
me l'a prêté sa coute rien si ça me
plaît c'est cool si ça me plaît pas
c'est pas très grave
allons-y et là je suis un petit peu
tombé des nues parce que je m'attendais
pas du tout du tout du tout à ça j'ai
trouvé le matos vraiment cool et j'ai
voulu aller un petit peu plus loin dans
les tests parce qu'ils se trouvaient que
la version que j'avais était pas une
version qui avaient toutes les
nouveautés software j'en ai parlé à
nikon ils ont décidé de m'envoyer un
super quittent ils ont été hyper sympa
là se quitte là dont je vous parlais
juste après il ya vraiment énormément de
choses à dire dessus je ne suis pas payé
pour faire cette vidéo je n'ai pas de
script à lire ou quoi que ce soit c'est
vraiment mon avis donc ne vous en faites
pas ce que je vais vous dire ce sera en
toute objectivité et c'est pas pour me
justifier ou quoi que ce soit c'est
juste pour que vous ayez tous les
éléments pour vous faire votre propre
aviez-vous mais avant de vous donner une
conclusion détaillé et ben on va voir ce
qu'il a 2 cuil
ce 7 6 il ya plusieurs choses dont il
faut qu'on parle et on va faire ça tout
de suite c'est parti alors déjà comme je
voulais montrer nikon propose un kit un
kit pour filmmaker dans lequel il ya
beaucoup d'éléments et saha par nikon
personne ne le propose alors bien sûr on
peut se faire ce genre de kits soi même
en achetant à droite à gauche les
différents éléments
mais là on vous propose directement
quelque chose et on sait clairement que
ça s'adresse à des gens qui vont vouloir
faire de la vidéo même si en photo les
et il cite abbas aussi pas mal parce que
dans ce kit hormis les objectifs qui ne
sont pas présents il ya absolument tout
ce dont vous avez besoin pour faire de
la vidéo vraiment tout la première chose
bien évidemment contournant le kit c'est
le nikon z6 il ya eu plein de rêves ue
de fait les deux très bonne vidéo
je vous mets des liens description
d'autres youtube heurts qui ont fait de
très bonnes review moi je vais quand
même vous en parler mais de façon assez
succincte le 7 6 et une caméra hybrique
plein format qui se rapproche en termes
de taille et de fonctionnalités du sony
alpha 7,3 du panasonic s1 et aussi du
canon eos
r on a donc dû plein format avec une
monture spécifique au nikon 7 6 et 7 7
mais nikon fournit une bague
d'adaptation pour pouvoir mettre
n'importe quel objectif nikon sur le
site en gros cette monture elle a la
particularité de mettre l'objectif très
très très très près du capteur et ça
c'est plutôt cool
en terme de vidéo en interne on peut
faire de la 4k jusqu'à 30 images par
seconde et de la full hd jusqu'à 120
images par seconde ce qui est plutôt
cool ce qui est dans la moyenne de ce
qui se fait généralement sur les
boîtiers de ce type pour ce qui est des
couleurs on est sur du cas de 0 8 bits
en interne ce qui n'est pas fou fou et
vous allez voir qu'on peut aller outre
ça et que c'est pas franchement une
limitation très très importante juste
qu'il est capable de faire et on va en
parler après pour ce qui est de
l'autonomie c'est vraiment très bon on
est mieux que sur le sony clairement en
plus dans le kit ya deux batteries qui
sont fournis donc on a largement de quoi
tenir une journée de shoot vraiment là
aussi rien à redire top en terme
d'ergonomie c'est ce qui m'a aussi
beaucoup surpris généralement quand on
passe d'une marque à une autre il ya un
petit temps d'adaptation plus ou moins
long pour se
faire au menu pour trouver où se
trouvent les fonctionnalités etc là
c'est vraiment hyper bien foutu on a un
écran tactile qui fonctionne très bien
des menus simples et claires ça me
change un petit peu la vie là dessus
beaucoup plus facile d'arriver à changer
le framerate est à changer tout ce qui a
changé à changer la résolution
voilà c'est ça va vite et c'est simple
en terme d'ergonomie toujours le boîtier
il est hyper bien fichu le simple fait
de pouvoir agrippé correctement la
poignée et de ne pas avoir le petit
doigt qui passe sous l'appareil hyper
chiant
chez sony c'est vraiment bien le grip
est bon la bécane est légère et les
objectifs comme le 35 mm avec lequel je
filme là son tout petit et c'est
pourtant un 35 mm f/1 8 donc c'est
vraiment léger et facile à prendre en
main on tient vraiment bien très très
très agréable à utiliser
enfin pour finir juste sur le boîtier et
puis après on passera sur le reste des
éléments du kit qui vont faire vraiment
la différence sur le boîtier on a des
couleurs qui vraiment vraiment sont très
sympas on est sur quelque chose d'assez
proche de la réalité je galère beaucoup
moins sur l'étalonnage qu'avec le sony
ça c'est clair et net les tempos sont
beaucoup plus fidèle et à défaut d'avoir
du log ou du hlg ben on a un mode flat
qui est certes pas le mode le plus
flatte de la terre mais le workflow qui
va derrière et quand même beaucoup plus
simple on arrive à avoir un résultat
sympa beaucoup plus facilement là pour
vous donner des genêts est strictement
rien changé à l'éclairage de la pièce on
a une plage dynamique qui est vraiment
très sympa là vous pouvez voir par
rapport à d'habitude j'avais des ombres
un peu plus présente et là il arrive à
choper un petit peu tous sur le visage
on a pas de zone vraiment noir on
man - de contraste à ce niveau là qu'on
peut rajouter en post prod si on veut
après ou pas et c#
c'est vraiment mémé ciselé au couteau la
netteté de ce boîtier couplée aux
objectifs que j'ai eues ici
vraiment c'est assez hallucinant quoi
vraiment on est au tcc c'est bluffant
alors vous allez me dire oui mais c'est
un petit peu comme tout ce qui se fait
sur le marché au final il n'y a pas
vraiment une grande différence l'image
elle est un peu plus typé les plus cheap
et de nikon mais bon voilà au final à
haisnes révolutionnaire et ben si on va
continuer d'aller voir ce qui est dans
le titre
et puis ça va vous montrer les
possibilités du machin truc de ouf
le deuxième élément qui vient dans le
kit c'est tout simplement une cage small
rig plutôt une demie cage donc qu'il va
permettre de rester léger mais de
pouvoir fixer tout un tas d'éléments
comme un micro comme une lumière
d'appoint
tiens j'ai oublié de la mettre la
lumière d'appoint généralement elle me
sert de backelite cela met de suite
bah ouais c'est oui oui voila je l'avais
oubliée je l'avais oublié m'en voudrez
pas un au moins jusque là dans la vidéo
donc vous savez que la petite backelite
la voilà donc une petite pause éclairage
dit qu'il y avait un truc qui n'allait
pas aussi 7,2 me cache mal riggle à un
petit plateau qui va permettre de
retirer l'appareil de la cage sans avoir
à tout davis et c'est très pratique
vraiment hyper bien foutu et surtout
surtout surtout on va pouvoir venir y
fixer la tomos ninja 5 qui est dans le
kit
alors qu'est ce que c'est là tomos ninja
5 c'est un moniteur déjà qui va vous
permettre d'avoir un grand écran de 7 ou
8 pouces déjà pour pouvoir monitorer un
petit peu ce que vous filmez et avoir
les infos dessus vous pouvez avoir un
histogramme vous pouvez avoir des zébras
vous pouvez avoir le focus picking bref
tout ce que vous voulez dessus pouvait
mettre des luttes dedans pour pré
visualiser un petit peu si vous utilisez
des luttes c'est le moniteur qui tue
vraiment on a toutes les infos dessus
mais c'est pas tout c'est pas tout il se
trouve que c'est ici là une sortie hdmi
qui va aller se brancher sur l'atome
hausse il l'a là mes amis ça change tout
parce que cette sortie hd et demi elle
va pouvoir permettre d'enregistrer sur
l'atome hausse que l'atom hausse aussi
il ne fait pas que moniteur il est aussi
enregistreurs on va venir lui mettre
carrément là c'est même plus des cartes
sd c'est un disque dur ou un ssd
directement dedans moi j'ai mis
carrément
un terrain comme ça tranquille et donc
on enregistre plus sur la carte sd mais
sur l'atome hausse et on va pouvoir
enregistrer tenez vous bien en propre
rêve ro oui on peut filmer en gros donc
pour ceux qui savent pas ce que c'est
l'euro s'est un petit peu comme en photo
en photo on peut prendre des photos en
jpeg c'est-à-dire compressé où on peut
les prendre en euros c'est à dire en
format brut avec un maximum d'infos on
fera une vidéo dédié justement au projet
euro un petit peu plus tard parce que
sinon la vidéo va durer une heure et
demie 1 à pascal may mais grosso modo ça
veut dire que on va avoir du 12 bits
donc en termes de couleurs c'est juste
dingue en 4k jusqu'à 30 images par
seconde pareil pour le full hd on peut
faire du progrès euros jusqu'à 50 images
par seconde aussi et concrètement ça
veut dire que on peut ajuster absolument
tout si votre plan est surexposé vous
pouvez baisser l'exposition il y aura
rien de cramer cie veau noir sont
bouchés pour remonter l'exposition il ya
de fortes chances qu'ils aient plein de
détails qui est quand même été capté
donc ça c'est un truc de fou
merci vous avez déjà un z 6 et qu'il n'a
pas cette fonctionnalité
c'est une option qui coûte 200 euros et
qui nécessitent un retour atelier mais
ça peut être mis sur le nikon et dans ce
kit s'est d'entrée de jeu s'est déjà mis
dedans c'est déjà prêts à l'emploi donc
on peut utiliser l'euro sans problème il
faut juste faire une petite mise à jour
de l'atome hausse pour être sûr qu' il
soit sur la bonne version de firmware
pour pouvoir l'utiliser mais voilà c'est
juste canon et pour vous donner une
petite idée le seul appareil
je parle pas de caméra je parle
d'appareil photo qui fait caméra qui
propose du rau en étant full frame c'est
le canon d'un des x mark iii qui coûte
environ 8000 euros voilà parce que oui
on en arrive au prix le z 6 coûte
environ 1800 euros ce qui n'est pas
donné mais ce qui est un prix à peu près
équivalent à tout ce qui se fait sur le
marché dans la même gamme
le kit lui il est proposé aux alentours
de 2800 euros avec le z si cela cache
mal rig l'atome hausse les câbles qui
vont avec les deux batteries
voilà tout le temps tout le toutim il
manquera juste les objectifs ce qui en
fait la caméra hybride la seule
d'ailleurs puisque l'un des x mark iii
n'est pas un hybride la seule caméra
hybride comme ça plein format a proposé
dure où il ya aussi black magic qui
propose du rau mais c'est pas du pain
forme bon il ya quand même quelques
petit point négatif à 7,6 parce que je
vous avais dit que je serai honnête
jusqu'au bout et que je vous donnerai
vraiment mon avis le premier point qui
pour moi est problématique c'est
l'impossibilité d'avoir un double
enregistrement on a un seul slot sd pour
enregistrer en interne et sur l'atome au
sénat en a qu'un seul disque dur pour
enregistrer en externe
donc ça c'est un petit peu gênant
puisque j'ai tendance à être un petit
peu parano raw avec mes cartes et tout
ça j'ai toujours un petit peu peur que
qu'il y a un truc je pars à kiki qui
marchent pas une carte qui merde et et
voilà perdre mes fichiers
donc ça c'est un petit peu gênant c'est
pas non plus un inconvénient de fou
puisqu'on a des cartes qui sont hyper
fiable c'est les cartes cf express mais
là aussi 200 balles la carte sd de 64
giga avec des débits de fou un dessus on
est d'accord mais 64 giga 200 balles il
n'y a pas moins cher c'est ça le truc
c'est que il ya des cartes sd qui sont
même plus cher que ça mais on a la
possibilité d'en lâcher des moins chères
là j'ai pris la moins chère que j'ai
trouvé et je les payais 200 balles donc
chiffre qui peut l'autre inconvénient
qui est un avantage aussi au final donc
ça ça dépend des productions que vous
allez faire c'est que le pro réseau
c'est hyper low vraiment hyper low faut
compter plusieurs gigaoctets d'espacé
par minute
ça fait vraiment très très lourd
vraiment laid
il faut avoir la capacité de stockage là
dessus mais on n'est pas obligé non plus
d'utiliser l'atome hausse est de prendre
le petit on peut juste partir sur le 7 6
qui a déjà des choses très très
intéressante a proposé la ici je filme
en interne avec le profil flat j'utilise
pas l'atome hausse parce que pour de
youtube il n'y a pas forcément dans le
jeu particulier ça serait plus un
désavantage d'utiliser la tomos là
dessus parce que ça me ferait un
workflow beaucoup trop important pour
youtube pour qu'au final
youtube ne comprennent tout et me
dégueulasse tôt un point là mais
clairement voilà j'étais pas convaincu
par 7 6 eh ben pour toutes les raisons
dont je vous ai parlé juste avant je
suis totalement convaincu
c'est d'ailleurs la raison pour laquelle
est bien dosé de 6,20 devenir ma caméra
youtube vous avez vu il ya le nouveau
studio il ya vraiment j'ai voulu mettre
le paquet sur youtube cette année en
2020 est vraiment m'occuper de vous
parce que parce que voilà je trouve que
ça se passe plutôt bien qu'on a des
retours et des échanges qui sont très
sympa et je me suis dit qu'avoir une
caméra dédiée à youtube
ça serait super et le z6 clairement et
la caméra rêvée pour faire ce que j'ai
envie de faire
sur youtube je garde tout le reste de
mon matériel pour les prestations me
permets voilà de l'essai du matériel
fixe ici et d'avoir tout de près sur les
étagères ou dans les sacs pour pouvoir
partir quand j'ai un client qui me
demandent une vidéo voilà là on est
royal mais caviar on est trop bien et
voilà les amis on a terminé sur 7,6
maintenant je vais vous dire un petit
peu ce que je vous ai prévu ce dont je
vous ai parlé en tout début de vidéo le
petit cadeau que j'ai envie de vous
faire pour mon anniversaire le mec pour
son anniversaire fait des cadeaux
alors si vous suivez les liens qui sont
dans la description je vous fais une
grosse promo sur la formation pour
apprendre à monter avec final cut que
j'ai fait sur ud et me voilà premier
cadeau
ensuite et ça se passe sur une chope qui
est sure you type je vais passer le pac
de l'ue de 25 euros à 15 euros pendant
une semaine
voilà ça c'est fait et enfin toujours
sur le choc youtube je vais faire un
pack avec les luttes et les préceptes
lightroom à 20 euros donc les luttes
plus les préceptes pour 20 euros
voilà en gros c'est ma grosse promo de
mon anniversaire pour vous alors voilà
on est au bout les amis n'hésitez pas à
mettre le traditionnel coup de
blaster si cette vidéo vous a plu pouvez
vous abonner cliquez sur la cloche
laïque et mettre votre avis un petit peu
sur cette vidéo aussi en plus deviner
mon âge dans les commentaires et puis
partager partager autour de vous cette
chaîne on est de plus en plus nombreux
ça fait hyper plaisir c'est grâce à vous
tous a donc le continuer à passer le mot
fait du bruit
et puis moi je vous dis comme d'habitude
rester curieux et à très bientôt pour
une prochaine vidéo j'ai loupé un mardi
voilà la semaine dernière il n'y a pas
eu de vidéo ça fait bizarre ça fait
bizarre j'avais pris le rythme et tout
mais là en ce moment mais tous les
clients se réveille au même moment voilà
vidéo pour avant-hier tu peut pas
traverser la france pour aller le faire
une vidéo est tout
oui oui oui il y avait plaisir je fais
toujours ça avec plaisir mais mais je
sais pas je suis sûr qu'il ya un des
réunions secrètes des entreprises et des
gens qui se disent on va tous lui m les
produits même moment juste pour voir
s'il y arrive tu vois
j'y arrive mais du coup j'ai loupé un
mardi quoi j'espère que vous m'en voulez
pas voilà